Today,
we are going to do something different
from what's happened so far in that we
are going to study the
dynamics of more than one body.
Or you might say,
look,
we already did this last week when I
studied the solar system where there are
planners moving around the sun.
So that makes up these two bodies,
the sign in the planet,
but actually the son was not doing
anything interesting in our analysis.
Son Just stood there as the source of
the gravitational force is a planet that
did all the orbiting and that
was a problem in two dimensions.
But I've only one body.
So now we're going to enlarge over
domain to more than one body or being
Newton's laws.
So let me start with the
simplest possible case.
Two bodies and I will again started
simplest case of they're moving in one
dimension.
Then we'll put in more.
So here is the one dimensional world
in these bodies are going to move
and this is my origin.
X equals zero.
And I'm going to imagine one point mass
and one located at x one other point.
Bass m two located at x two.
Oh
No.
We know everything that is to know about
these masses from the likes of Newton,
which I'm going to write down.
The first mass obeys does equation
m the two x one over d t square.
That's Mia, right? But I'm going to write
this in a notation that's more succinct.
Um, prior to writing the second
day they would have this fashion.
I'm going to write it as follows.
M One x one with two dots in it.
The two dots telling you is to
derivatives. If there's one daughters,
one day they would have
$3 to three data centers.
Of course at some point there's
notation becomes unwieldy,
but you never deal with more than two
derivatives. So this works. This is Amy,
so don't forget the docs, okay?
This is not some foreign alphabet.
every.is it did have it.
You should remember that when I do the
subsequent manipulation, that's Amy.
And that's equal to force on body one.
No,
look at the body one.
And ask what are the forces acting on it
that it could be the whole universe but
we going to divide that into two parts.
The first part is going to be the force
on body one due to body to which I'm
going to denote by f one
two f southern rotation.
You and I agree that's the forest in
one duty to then that's the force on one
due to the external world.
E stands for external.
That means everything outside these two
do universe as many bodies I have to
speak these two guys they're wanting to
and the force on one is some of it's due
to too and some of what
to do to everything else.
Similarly,
I have another equation and two x two
double.is the fourth son to do do one plus
the force on to due to the outside world.
What do you mean by outside world?
Maybe these two guys have an extra some
planet and the planet is way over to the
right. It's pulling all of them towards
the planet with some gravitational force,
so everything else is called external
like one and two for example.
Are connected by a spring.
The spring is not that important.
It's a way of transmitting force
from one body to the other.
If you're compress the spring and let
it go, these two masters at white bread,
back and forth under the influence
of the other person's force.
That's an example of f one two
and a half to one for example,
the spring is compressed at this
incident is trying to push them out.
That means really one is trying to push
to outwards that way too is trying to
push one to the left this way.
That's an example of f
one two and half to one.
The external force could be due to
something extraneous to these two bodies.
So one example is the
surface of the earth.
I take these two masters
connected by a sprain.
There is mass one and here's my stew.
I squashed the spring.
If there is no gravity,
they would just go vibrating up and down,
but let them fall under
the field of gravity.
So they're also experiencing the mg due
to gravity so they will both fall down
and also oscillate relate to each other.
They're all described by this equation.
This will be the spring force
transmitted from one to two.
This would be the force of gravity article
could be electric force at any other
force to to anything else.
I'm not interested.
Now here's the interesting
manipulation we are going to perform.
We're going to add the two things on
the lefthand side and equate them to
whatever they get on the right hand side.
Then I get m one x one double.plus m
two x two double doc and that's going to
be,
I'm going to write it in a particular way.
If one external plus F to
external plus f one two f two one
I think you have some idea
where I'm headed now, so what's,
what's the next thing we could say?
Yes,
yes, because that's the third law of
new whatever the underlying force,
gravity spring,
anything forced on one [inaudible] to
enforce them to do two one will cancel and
everything I get today, the whole lecture
is mainly about this one simple result,
this cancellation.
Then this whole thing.
I'm going to write this ethics journal
meaning the total external force.
On this two body system.
So I have this peculiarity question.
I'm going to rewrite it in a way that
brings it to the form in which is most
useful.
I'm going to introduce a new guy,
capital x,
as you know,
that's called the center
of mass coordinate and it's
defined as m one x one plus
m two x two divided by capital m.
Capital m is just the total
mass and one plus empty.
If I do that,
this is a definition,
then we can write the
secret mission as follows.
I would write it and then we can take
over time seeing that it is correct.
So this is really the big equation.
Yeah.
What did you guys try to
fill in the blanks in your
head? This is really correct.
On the lefthand side,
I have capital m times x double doc,
so I have really m one plus m two
times x double dot. If you
take the double door, this guy,
it's an one x one double.plus m to
extrude double dot divided by m one plus m
two
so the left hand side is indeed this.
That's all I want you to check.
So take this expression divided by the
total mass and multiply by the total mass.
Well,
the multiplying by the turtle masters
here and when divided by the total mass
you get the second didn't it threw
off the center of mass coordinate.
So what have I done?
I have introduced a fictitious entity,
the center of mass central
Mass USA location, capital x,
some grant of a weighted average
of x one and x two by weighted,
I mean if I'm on an m, two would equal
then capitol and bill be two, two,
two times at mass and you'd just get x
one plus x two over to central mass would
sit right in between,
but if m one is heavier,
it'd be tilted towards and
one of inclusive vehicle
be tilted towards them too.
It's a way to sum that gives a certain
coordinate that is nothing present at
that location.
There's nobody there.
All the stuff they did here or that
the central mass is the location of a
mathematical entity.
It's not a physical entity.
If you go there and say
watch are the central mass,
you typically won't find anything
and it behaves like a body.
After all,
if you just said,
I've learned Newton's laws and I walk into
this room and I say this, I won't say,
well this guy's talking about a body
of mass capital m undergoing some
acceleration due to the force
for the center of mass is a body whose
mass seems to be the total mass at these
two particles.
Who's acceleration is controlled
by the same as Newton's law,
but the right hand side contains only
the external forces. This is the key.
All the internal forces have canceled
out and what remains to the external
force. Now your fraternity
started even got three bodies.
You can do a similar manipulation and
again you'll have f one two and half to
three and have three or two and so on.
They will all canceled and walk through.
The man will be a similar thing,
but this is the total external force.
So if I can say this in words,
what we have learned is that the
advantage of introducing a quantity called
center of mass is that it responds only
to the total force and doesn't care
about internal forces.
So I give you an example.
So he had a some at a plane,
right?
It's in flight and a couple of guys that
are having a fight punching each other
and so on. The rest of the
passenger says enough is enough.
And to throw them out there just
floating around affecting each other's
dynamics. And of course this person
will feel a forced you to that person.
That person would feel of
course you to this person.
But what I'm telling you is the center
of mass is going to drop like a rock.
It's going to accelerate
with the forest MGH.
I'm just going to accelerate with Ge.
So at one point that this person may be
having the upper hand and maybe hear the
other person may be down here,
but follow the central mass,
you find there's simply
falls under gravity.
So the mutual forces do not affect
the dynamics of the center of mass
art.
For example.
Suppose at some point this person blows
the other one up into say to Samurai
that make it simple,
cuts them up in two pieces.
So let me got three bodies now,
first protagonist and the other two.
Now unfortunately somewhat decimated.
Now you can take these three bodies,
find their center of mass.
It'll be the same thing.
It'll just keep falling down.
So even though the system is
becoming more and more complicated,
you cannot change the dynamics
of the center of mass.
It responds only to the external force.
If this fight was taking place in
outer space, but there's no gravity,
then as this fight continues and people
are flying in parts of laying everywhere,
central mass, we'll just be in one
location not doing anything. Yes,
no, that's what I'm saying.
Center of mass. If it changes,
it can certainly, no one says the
central mass cannot accelerate.
It can accelerate due to external forces.
But if there were no external forces,
then the center of mass will behave like
a particular with no force for the not
moving to begin with.
It won't move later or if it is moving
to begin with that he maintain a constant
velocity.
So here's another example.
Now you can obviously generalize
this to more than one dimension.
If you're living in two dimensions,
you will introduce an x coordinate,
introduce a white coordinate,
and then you will have the center of
mass as m r double dot equal to f and r
would be m one odd one plus m two r two
divided by the total mass r one and r
two are just the location.
Now been two dimensions of
these two masses. So here,
the same one here,
the m too,
and the center of mass you can check
will be somebody in between the line
joining the two points,
but it'll now be a vector.
So here's another example.
So you'll take a complicated object.
It's got masters and there's God springs.
It's connected with thread
and chains and everything.
You throw the whole mess into the air.
All the different parts of it are
juggling and doing complicated movements.
But if you follow the center of mass,
in other words,
that every instant you take the m one
odd one plus m two r two plus MTR three
and so on,
divided by the total mass that coordinate,
would it simply be following the
parabolic path of a body curving under the
gravity?
Yeah.
If at some point this complicated
object fragments into two chunks,
one with land he had in one would
land there, but at every incident,
if you follow the center of mass,
it'll go as if nothing happened and it
will land here in central mass that's not
cared about internal forces
but only about external forces.
That's the main point and it was designed
in such a way that external forces
canceled in those dynamics.
So everything I'm going to do today is
to take that equation and mixed doubles
dot equalsF or m r double dot equal f
in vector form and did you is all the
consequence? No. First of all,
you should realize that if you've
got several bodies, say three bodies,
then I would define the
center of mass to be m I x.
I divided but some or what am I?
This is the shorthand.
I'm going to write it only once,
but you should know about the notation
means if there's eye from one to three it
really means m one x one plus m two x
two m three x three divided by m one plus
m two lesson three. This summation
is a notation mathematicians,
they've introduced where the index, I
will go over the range from one to three.
Every term you let, I take three
different values and they do the song.
An exercise I've given to you guys
to pursue at home is the following.
If I got three bodies, one, two, and three
defined the center of mass,
you can either go to this formula,
do all the next ones and add them up,
or do you also have the following options?
You can pick any two of them, say
the first two, but get the third one.
Take these to find their center of mass.
Let's call it x one and to add with that
total mass m one two which just just m
one plus m two trade these two for a new
fictitious object and put that here and
forget these two, but on that one point,
the deposit, the massive, these two,
now you take the center of mass of
this object with the third object,
by the same weighting process,
m three x three pluses,
m one two x one two
divided by the total mass.
You will get the same answer as here.
What I'm telling you is if you've got
many bodies and you want the center of
mass of all of them,
you can take a subset of them,
replace them by their center of mass,
namely all that mass sitting at the
center of Mass d plus the other half by
their massive ego,
that center of mass.
And finally find the center of mass
of these two centers of mass properly
weighted and that will
give you this result.
Okay. So, uh,
before I explain that equation
and find all the consequences,
we have to get used to finding central
of mass for a variety of things.
As long as they give you a 10 masses
are countable number of masses,
we just got to plug it in here. It's
a very trivial exercise. Thanks.
Become more interesting if I give you
not a set of discrete masses with this
great locations.
[inaudible] namely countable set up passes
where they give you a rod like this.
This is a rod of mass m and l and I
say where does his center of mass?
So we have to adapt the definition
that we have for this problem.
So what definition, what should I do?
Well this is my origin of coordinators.
You've had a set of masses but definite
locations. I know how to do it,
but this is a continual,
the trick then is to say I take a distance
x from the left hand and I cut myself
a very thin sliver of thickness dx.
Yeah.
That sliver has got a certain mass
and I argue is that a definite distance
x from the court in its origin they
finish speaking, you will say, what
do you mean by definitely distance?
It's got a wit the x. So one part of it
is it x? The other part is of x plus Dex.
So it doesn't have a definite coordinate.
What if the x is going to zero?
This argument will eventually be invalid.
So dx goes to zero.
That's delivered Hasad
definitely location,
which is just the x
coordinate of where I put it.
So to find the center of mass,
which is consists of multiplying
every mass base location and adding,
let me first find how much mass
is sitting here. Let me it Delta,
how much massive sitting there.
But I do the following,
I take the total mass and divide
by l last the mass per unit length
and this fellow has a wit the DX.
So the massive this little
slivers and Wilbert Ldx.
Yeah.
Therefore the center of mass that I want
his phone by taking this sliver of that
mass multiplying by its coordinate
and summing over all the slivers,
which is what we do by the
integral from zero to l.
Then I should divide by the total mass,
which is just an,
you can see now if you
do this calculation,
I get one over l the Nigga integral x
Dx from zero to l and that's going to be
elsewhere over too.
So if you do that you'll get allover to,
I'm not doing every step in the calculus
because at this point we should be able
to do this without every detail.
So the center of mass of this Rod,
that's nobody's price is
right in the mid point,
but it's assumed that the rod is uniform,
but it's like a baseball bat.
They could at one end and tender
at the other end. Of course,
no one is saying that, but we have assumed
the mass per unit length, namely Ammo.
Is this a fixed number?
I'm over l and then this is the answer,
but there are other ways to get this
result without doing all the work.
Okay?
So we would like to learn that other
methods because it'll save you a lot of
time.
It must be clear to most people that the
center of mass of these writers at the
center. But how do we argue that?
How do you make it official?
You could do the integrity,
you will get the answer,
but I want to short circuit the integral
and here's the trick is not going to
work for arbitrary bodies. If I give
you some freezy object like this,
you cannot do anything.
But this is a very symmetric object.
You can sort of tell
if I take the midpoint,
that is as much stuff to the
right as to the left in some way.
You want to make that argument
Pharma and you do the following.
Suppose I have a bunch of masses and
the object is really not even regular.
This general coordinates,
if I replaced every x bar minus x,
okay,
so I'd actually change this Arctic.
So this is really, it looks like this.
Here's the object
supposedly plays every x bar minus x
that's reflecting the body or on this axis
it will look like this.
It'd be getting to the right instead of
the left. So don't go by my diagrams.
You know what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to draw the middle
remained of this object the other way.
Then I think it's clear to everybody.
If I do that x one go to minor sex
because then there's averaging am I excise
some load all the masses.
If every x goes to minus x center of mass,
we'll go to minus x but not take
this rod and transport every party.
Room two is negative coordinate and
you take that guy and put it here.
The Rod looks the same
is it all looks the same.
The central mass miss look the same.
That means minus sex has to be equal to
exit itself and the only answer this x
equal to zero.
So without doing any detailed calculation,
you argued that the answer is
x equal to zero. To do this.
Of course you must cleverly pick your
coordinates so that the symmetry of the
body is evidence.
If it took the body like this and
you took a reflection on this point,
it goes into the body. Flipped over.
There is not much you can say about it.
So what do you really want to do is to
pick a point of reflection so that upon
reflection the body looks the same.
The body looks the same.
The answer must be the same,
but they will argue the answer
must be minus of itself.
That's for the answer to zero.
This is how the central of massive
symmetric bodies can be fun.
So we know the answer for this Rod.
Suppose they give you not a 10 rod,
but eh, Radha non zero with we
want to know it's center of mass.
We're not going to do any more work.
Now by symmetry,
I can argue that this has to be the
center of mass because I can take uh,
every point here and turn it into the
point that by changing y two minus y
therefore capital,
why it will become minus capital wine.
But the body looks the
same after this mapping.
So capital way zero and similarly capitol
x's, you don't that the center of mass.
Now what if I give you this object?
Okay.
Nobody wanted to try that.
Yeah.
What do you guys like to try this?
Yes.
Can you tell me where the
central mass should be? Yeah,
no, no. The guy in front of you. Yes.
Objects.
Okay. Is that what your answer was?
Okay, so the correct answer is the place,
this mass by all efforts, mass,
whatever it is, sitting here,
they play this one by all of its mass
sitting here. Then forget the math,
the big bodies to be placed in by points.
Then you just got two masters located here
and you can find the weighted average.
It may be somewhere there.
Okay,
now let's take one more object then
I'm pretty much done with finding these
centers of mass.
The object I'm going to pick,
you see a triangle that looks like this.
It's supposed to be symmetric even
though I've drawn it this way,
that is B and that is B,
and that distance is h.
Let the mass B m
we had,
it's the center of mass.
This optic,
again by symmetry.
You can tell that the white coordinator
at the center of mass must lie on this
line because if I think
take y two minus Y,
it maps onto itself so it looks the same
but it's supposed to reverse capital
capitol. Why? Therefore why is
minus Y in that photo is zero,
so it's evidently lying
somewhere on this line.
I cannot do further calculations of this
type by saying where it is on the line
because it is no longer a symmetry in
the x direction is symmetric in the wild
andro flipping why,
but I cannot say take x two minus x.
In fact, if I take extra minus
x, this one looks like this.
It doesn't map into itself,
but I can pick any point here.
If I take extra minus sex,
the object looks different.
It looks like that object and relating
one object to another object is not what
I'm trying to do.
I want to relate it to the same
object that cannot be done for x.
It can be done for y for x.
You got to do some honest work.
The honest work we will do
then is to take this thing,
take a strip here with location x and
with the DX and the height of that strip
here is why,
why of course babies with X.
Yeah,
so I'm going to argue that to find
the center of mass of this triangle,
I can divide it into vertical
strips with tech paddle,
do each other and find the central mass
by adding the weighted average of all
these things. For that, I need to know
what's the mass of the shaded region,
so let's call it delta. In the mass
of the shaded region is the mass,
but you're in an area. I'd find the
area later on in terms of B and h,
but this is mass media in India, but then
I need to know the area of this trip.
I'm going to give the answer,
but because I don't have time to probe it,
but you should think about what the answer
for the area of the shaded region is.
It's got a height to why and
has got the width, the x,
it's not quite a rectangle
because the edgers lately tapered,
but when Delta is goes to zero,
it's going to look like a rectangle.
So the idea is to why delta x,
but I don't want to write everything
in terms of why I wanted to write it in
terms of x.
Then I do similar triangles.
Similar triangles tells me that
why Overby is x over at h Emily,
that triangle come back to that triangle
tells me why divided by B is x divided
by age.
Therefore the y here can be
replaced by the x over age.
So that is the mass of the sliver here
and are centered is obviously here.
So that is a mass there.
There's somebody else that I've got to
do the weighted average of all of them to
remember.
I don't just integrate this over x,
let me just give me the mass of the body.
I should multiplied by a further
x and then do the integral.
So what I really wanted to do to find
the center of mass ex used to take that
mass. I got am over a,
that is a tool that's an age
that is a B Benson,
x from there and another x because you
have to multiply this by the x coordinate
of this thing because that's the
coordinator of the central mass of this
that our two x's.
That's what he got to remember.
So that should be
integrated from zero to age.
That'll give me h cubed
over three so I get to em,
the Eh h h cubed over three.
Now you know what?
There's one more thing we have to do.
We must replace the area of the triangle
by one half base times altitude,
which is Bah. Well, I also forgot to do,
I did everything by the mass because the
center of mass is this weighted average
divided by the total math.
So I got a divided by one
over there like claim.
If you do this and cancel everything,
you will get the answer of two thirds age.
Okay.
So not surprisingly,
the center of mass of this is
not halfway to the other end,
but two thirds of the way because it's
top heavy, the side of it, the heavier,
this is the level of calculus you
should be able to do in this course.
We are able to take some body,
slice it up in some fashion and find
the location of the center of mass.
You come by and symmetry arguments with
actual calculation for this liver by
symmetry. You know the central mass is
at the center. You don't waste your time,
but then when you add these guys,
there is no further cemetery you can use.
You have to do the actual work.
So what have I done so far?
What I've done is point out to you that
when you work with extended bodies are
more than one body.
We can now treat the entire body,
replace the body by single
point for certain purposes.
The single point that's called the
center of mass. When am I attend?
All the mass contemplated
the center of mass.
So you have created a brand new entity,
which is fictitious.
It doesn't mask with a total mass.
It has a location equal to
the center of mass and it,
it moves in response to the total force
and is not aware of internal forces.
And that's what we want to explore it.
I already gave you a clue as to what
the implications are, but let me,
let me now take a thorough
analysis of this basic equation
and r w.
Dot.
Equals F.
We just got to analyze the consequence.
So there are several cases
you can consider. Case one
is f external,
not equal disease.
So this is a two bodies subject to
mutual forest and to an outside force.
The simplest example, I wanted to
give it to you, but I'll repeat it.
We're not going to do
this in great detail.
We all know if I had a point
mass like this, it will do that.
What I'm not telling you is for take
a complex body made up 20,000 parts,
all connected with each other,
pushing and pulling.
If you flipped that crazy
tongue thing in the air,
it'll do all kinds of directions
and juggling as it moves around.
But if you fall in it's center of mass,
it's center of mass of followers,
simply a parabola because the
external force on it is just mg.
So it will be m r double dot equals m
g and that's just motion with constant
acceleration in the way that action
and it just a predictable problem.
Okay.
And I had repeat once more for emphasis
that if this object broke into two
objects, typically what will happen is
one will fly there and one will land here.
But in every instance if you
found their center of mass,
you will find it proceeds as if
nothing happened. For example,
if you have an explosive device that blows
them apart, the pieces are all flying.
But that is coming from one part of the
piece pushing and another part of the
piece.
But that those forces that have no
interest with as far as the external force
score say distilled gravity. So the
central of massive continue traveling
beyond that, I'm not going to
do too much with this thing.
So let me now go to case to
case too.
If you want case to a is
f external equal to zero.
What does mean if f external is zero,
that means this is zero.
That miss m r double doctor zero.
That means m R.
Dot.
Is a constant because it's not changing.
Who is this? Mr? What does it stand for?
Well,
it looks like the following.
If you take a single particle
of mass m and velocity X.
Dot. We use the symbol of p maybe haven't
ever used it before in the course and
that's called the momentum.
Yeah,
we'll let them hold the body is this
peculiar combination of mass and velocity.
In fact,
in terms of momentum,
they may write Newton's law instead of
saying it's m Dvdt it just m a you can
also write it as d by Dt of envy because
MSA constantly and you can take it
inside the dead averted and
that we can write as the PBT
sometimes instead of
saying forces buy stamps,
acceleration people often say forces
the rate of change and momentum.
Today, there is a momentum of a body
is changing, is the applied force,
so you've have not introduced to the
notion of momentum well here at this,
so if you think about it that way,
this looks like the momentum of the center
of mass and we are told the momentum
of the central mass does not change
if there are no external forces,
but the momentum of the
central of massive buddy,
simple interpretation in terms of the
parts that make up the center of mass.
Let's see what it is. Let's
go back here. Remember,
let me just take two bodies
and you will get the idea.
It's m one plus m two historical m
and let's take just one dimension.
When there's an x
one.plus m two x two dot.
They might've been in one plus
m two that is what an x.is
the m one plus m two cancels here and
you find this is just p one plus p to
let's use the symbol capital p for
momentum or the center of mass.
The momentum of the center of mass is the
some of the momentum of the two parts.
But what you're learning is,
so let me write it one more time.
If FX journalists equal to zero,
then p one plus p two
an art change with time.
This is a very,
very basic and fundamental property
and it's in fact one another result
that survives all the revolutions of
relativity and quantum mechanics.
Well,
what I've said for two
bodies as true for 10 bodies,
you just do the summation over more terms.
So let me say in words what I'm saying.
Take a collection of bodies or to give
an instance. Everything is moving.
It's got his own velocity and its own
momentum. Add up all the momentum.
If you the one dimension, just add
the numbers, different true dimension.
Add the vectors.
You get a total momentum that total
momentum does not change if there is no
outside forces acting on.
So a classic example is two
people are standing on ice.
That total momentum is zero to begin with
and the ice is capable of incapable of
any force along the plane. It's going to
support you vertically against gravity,
but if it friction list,
it cannot do anything in the plane,
then the claim is that if you and I
are standing and be pushed against each
other and be fly apart,
my momentum has to be exactly the opposite
of your momentum because initially
you're split.
Mine was zero.
That cannot change because I don't wake
so forced to save two particles push
against each other. They can only
do so without changing the tone.
Okay,
so p one plus B two does not change.
And here's another context in which is
important support that is a mass and one
going with some velocity be one and
here's the second mass him to going with
some velocity be too.
They collide when they collide.
All kinds of things can happen.
I mean in one may bump his head
on that and come backwards.
Audit could be heavy object that pushes
everything in the forward direction.
At the end of the day,
you will have some m one
going with the new velocity.
Be One frame and m to going
with a new philosophy.
We to prime and what I'm telling you is
that m one v One plus M Two v two will
be equal to m one v one prime.
Let's aim two three to
prime your net collision.
Of course,
one block exerts a force on the other
block and the other block exerts an
opposite force on this block.
That's the reason why even though
individually that momentum could be very
different. Finally, the momentum
will add up to the same total.
Here's a simple example.
You can show that if this mass and
that mass at equal and say this one has
addressed, that will come
soon. Here's this. You can
show under certain conditions,
this one will come to rest in. This
will start moving with the speed of the,
the target will move with
the speed or the projectile.
So moment of individual
objects have changed.
One was moving before this nonmoving,
one was at rest. It's moving,
but when you add up the
total doesn't change.
And this is called the law
of conservation of momentum,
so that's so important. I'm just going
to write it down here one more time
and the basic result is if
external forces are zero,
then p one [inaudible] p two last B three
and so on before would be p one prime
list B, two prime, less
beat, three prime and so on.
We had this means before and that means
after and what's it Ben is before when
it's after pick any two times
in the life of these particles.
It's like law of conservation of energy,
but we said e one equals z to that
one and booster for before and after.
Well here we cannot use one and two for
before and after because one and two and
three are labeling particles.
So the before quantities
or written without a prime.
The African studies are written with
a prime. Everybody followed this.
Pretty important.
You follow the statement and follow the
conditions under which it's balance that
cannot be external forces. For example
in the collision of these two masses,
if the restriction between
the blocks in the table,
you can imagine they collide and
they both come to rest after awhile.
What are generally that moment of finally
they don't? What happened? Well, he had,
you have an explanation,
namely the force of friction was
an external force acting on them.
What I'm saying is that the only force in
the block is the one due to each other.
Then the total moment and will not change.
So the case that I consider to a was
external force equals zero but center of
mass was moving
because it had a momentum.
Then the claim is that
momentum will not change.
I'm coming to the last case,
which is if you want case to be,
yes,
external forces are zero,
a center of mass
was zero.
Other words center of mass was addressed.
Okay.
Do you find this different
cases complicated than,
I don't mind telling you one more time.
The center of mass behaves
like a single object.
Responding to the external force
is clear to the external forces.
Nonzero central mass will
accelerate external forces.
Zero central mass will not
accelerate their cases. One and two,
two and two B are the following.
If it does not accelerate,
Isabella city will not change.
So then you have the two cases.
It had a velocity which had
maintained audit, had no velocity,
in which case it does not even move.
See if you apply f equals m a to a body
and there is no forces you cannot see
the body will be rest, go to the
body, will maintain the velocity.
So if it had a velocity would go at
the velocity. If it was addressed,
a little remain at rest.
Same goes for the center of mass.
If the center of mass was moving,
it'll preserve his momentum.
That really means the sum of the
moment of the individual pieces will be
preserved.
If it was addressed since the external
forces zero it will remain at rest.
So I want to look at the
consequence of this one.
I could have done them in either order.
I can take the case whether there's no
external force, there is no motion art.
I can this.
I chose to do it the opposite way,
but it took the most complicated
case, but external forces, not zero.
Then I took the case where it is zero,
but the central mass was moving to
begin with and therefore it has to keep
moving no matter what.
And the simplest cases,
central mass was at rest then is not
moving now and it will never move.
So let me give an example of
where the idea comes into play.
We looked at the planetary
motion of the sun and the earth
and I said the earth goes around the sun.
So let's look at it a little later that
year and the only force between the
earth and the sun is a
mutual forcer gravitation.
Now my question to you is,
is this picture of the sun sitting here
and the earth moving around acceptable
or not? In view of what I've said, yes.
Neutral.
Yeah,
but that's the answer to the problem.
But what is wrong if I just say
the son remains here in the earth,
goes in a circle,
which is what we accepted last night.
Okay,
that's certainly, that's one way.
Do you understand what he said?
He said the momentum of
the sun is not changing.
The momentum of the earth is changing.
So the total momentum is changing,
but total momentum cannot change.
So that's not acceptable.
But in terms of center of mass,
you can say something else. Yes,
it's moves. Maybe you can tell me,
you cannot point out from that,
but tell me which way
you think it's moving.
Yeah,
right in the beginning it's somewhere
here. A little later there's dead lifts.
There's the central mass would do this
if the picture that I gave you last time
was actually correct.
So a son,
a finite mass staying at
and a planet orbit thing,
an owner that is simply not acceptable
because the center of mass is moving
without external forces
that's not allowed. Artists,
he said the momentum is constantly
changing. This guy has no momentum.
That gets a momentum that points this
way now and points that we later.
But look what I've said here.
Take one and two to be the earth and the
sun doesn't add up with the same number.
So we sort of know what
the answer should be.
We know that the thing that cannot move,
it's not the sun and it's not the earth,
it's the center of mass. That's
what cannot move. If it does,
an elite was addressed, it'll remain
addressed. So the center of mass,
if it cannot move, so let's start
off the sun here. Start out.
The earth here joined them.
The central mass is some bad here.
Actually the sun is so much
more massive than the earth.
The central mass lights inside the sun.
But I'm taking another solar system where
the sun is a lot bigger than the earth,
but not as big as an iPad world.
So I can show the central
mass here that cannot move.
So what that means is a little later,
the planet is here and I wanted
to keep the center there.
The Sun has to be here and somewhat
later when the planners, they're,
the sun has to be here.
So what will happen is the sun will go
around on a circle of smaller radius,
the planet, and go around on
a circle of a bigger radius.
Always around the center of mass,
so you've got this picture and I was
like a Dumbbell, asymmetric big guy here,
smaller here,
fixed that and turn it.
You get a trajectory for the sun and
you get it radically for the earth on a
bigger circle.
Centered remains fixed
so you feel played. Loss of gravity.
I've given you a homework problem.
You've got to be careful of the board.
One thing when I played
the law of gravity,
you may apply to the earth for example.
Then you will say the center portal,
centripetal acceleration,
NV squared over r is the force of gravity.
When you do that calculation,
be careful be is the velocity of the
planet and when you do the MV squared over
r, the r you put will be the distance to
the center of mass from where you are.
That'd be the NV squared over R,
but when you create that
to the force of gravity,
it a g m one m two over r squared for
that are it is the actual distance from
the earth to the sun that you should
keep because the force of gravity is a
function of the distance
between the planets,
not between the planet
and the center of mass.
The actual force on the earth is really
coming not from here but on the other
side of this where the sun is.
But luckily at every instance the sun
is constantly pulling it towards the
center of the circle.
So very clever solution.
Planet moves around a circle.
It doesn't acceleration to where to center
and somebody is providing the force,
but there's somebody who's not at the
center but always on the other side of the
line joining you to the center.
So you still experience a force.
They were the center under the action
of that forest. You can show it,
we'll have a circular orbit and you can
take some time calculating now relation
between time period
and radius and whatnot.
So this is called the two body problem.
So this is one example.
Where do you realize, hey,
central mass, if we follow it,
it cannot be moving and therefore the
actual motion of planners and more
complicated than we thought.
Okay,
then that is a whole slew of problems.
One can do
that.
The center of mass is not moving.
So I'll just give you a couple
of examples. Then I will stop,
but I won't do the numbers.
Here's one example.
That is a carriage that contains a horse
and the hardest is on this far end.
And as they tell us to do,
uh, we won't draw the hearts.
We just say it's the point mass m and
the railway carriage is the big mass,
capital m and let's say the left
hand of the railway carriage is here.
You cannot see the horse.
Yeah.
Horses inside the hearts decides to know
is that I've tired of sitting on this
side of this room.
I'm going to the other side.
The hardest goes to the other side.
First of all,
you will know something's
going on without looking in.
Because when the hardest moves to the
left, the cat, it has to move to the right
first. Convince yourself that
it has to move somewhere.
Because originally the center of mass
between these two objects, that one,
and that one is something in between.
Somewhere here if the heart scan,
but that side central mass is
now the average of those two,
which is some bad over there in central
mass is moved and that's not allowed.
Central mass cannot move.
So if the separate off mass
originally on that line,
it has to remain in that line.
So what will happen in the end
is that the horse will come here,
the center of the carriage will be that,
but the central mass would
come out the same way.
So typical problem you guys will be
expected to solve. We look like this,
given all these masters and
given the length of the carriage,
find out how much the caddied moves.
So you think you can do that? Uh, give
some numbers and plug in the things.
For example,
this guy is that at a distance,
l over to this.
The hardest is that it listens.
L make this your origin or coordinate.
Take the weighted average of those two
and get the x coordinate at the center of
mass.
You don't have to worry
about the why because there's
nothing happening in the y.
So the x coordinate of that and that'll
be somewhere here at the end of the day.
Let us see it as more
than unknown distance d,
which is what you're trying to calculate.
Recompute the center of mass.
When you do that,
you remember that the center of the
carriage is Ello were two plus d from this
origin,
the heart system,
the distance d from the origin
equally the centers of mass,
and you will get an equation that the
only unknown will be d and You solve for
the and you'd tell you,
we'll tell you how much it moves.
Anybody have a question about
how you attack this problem?
Find the center of mass before,
find a central mass after equate them
and that linear equation we'll have one
unknown, which is the d by which the
candidates more than you can solve for.
Okay,
here's another problem
that's uh,
here. This is, sure. And here is a boat.
Yes.
Right? Maybe I'm sure the
board like a board. Here it is.
Okay.
That's the book.
No,
you are here.
So the board has a certain mass,
which we can pretend this concentrated
there you have a little mass m and the
board is at a distance,
say d from the shore and you are at a
certain distance x from the edge of the
boat and you want to get out.
Okay, you want to go to shore.
So what do you do?
So if you're superman or superwoman,
you just take off and you land where
you want. What supplies do you have?
Limited jumping capabilities,
very natural that you want to come as far
to the left as possible. And then John,
suppose it is true that d we just say
three meters is the maximum you can
possibly jump, but as you cannot
jump the plastics. So you said,
let me go to the end then I'm safe
because I can jump the distance.
D and again we know
that's not going to be,
it's not going to work because when
you move, look, it's very simple.
If you move and nobody else moves,
we got a problem because if you found
the center of mass with one location for
you and you change your location and
nothing has changed the central mass,
we'll change it. That's not allowed here.
I'm assuming that I know how to
sort of force this in real life.
The water will exert horizontal force,
but there's an ignored in this
calculation that no horizontal forces,
if you move,
everything else has to move.
So what'll happen is that when you
move the board would a move from there,
maybe somewhere over to the right leg.
This,
you are certainly at
the edge of the board,
but the board has moved a little extra
distance delta and you have to find the
delta.
You find it by the same trick.
Find the center of mass
of you and the board.
Preferably with this as the origin.
You can use any origin
you want for central mass.
It's not going that is not
going according to anybody,
but it's convenient to pick the shortest,
your origin point,
the way that some of your location in
your mass port location and boards mass at
the end of the day,
put yourself on the left end of the boat
and let's say it does more the distance
delta. So the deal distance
now is deep plus delta.
That's what you are.
That was l over two is where the center
of the borders find the new center of
mass and he quit them and you will find
how much the board would a mode and that
means you have to jump a distance deeply.
Plus Delta.
Everybody followed that. That's another
example of its central Madison move.
Now let's ask what happens next.
So you leap in the air. Okay,
I got add barn. What do you think
is happening when you add barn?
Yes. Go ahead. What's happening? The book.
Sure.
It'll be moving. And why do you
say it? And we'll be moving?
Yeah,
cause the center of a mess.
There's one way to say that central mass
cannot move if you move to the left,
the border moved to the right.
That's equivalent way to say that.
Yes,
right. Momentum cannot change. Originally
momentum. Oh zero nobody was moving.
If suddenly you're moving, the board
has to move the other way. Of course,
it doesn't move at the same
velocity or the same speed.
Most of the same momentum.
So the big game of the both types of
small B of the board will equal your small
lamp times your Big v. Other words,
you, let's say move with the big speed.
The board moves with the smallest speed
than these two numbers in magnitude
would be equal. So they feel, you know,
going on one of the big cruise
ships you dump on the short,
you're not going to notice the
movement of the shape of the ship.
But it technically speaking, it
does move the other way. Okay,
you have to add a barn. Okay.
Then in a few seconds later,
you collapsed on the shore. You're
right there. What's happening? The boat.
Is it going to stop now
your momentum is zero.
Yes,
yes.
Everybody agree?
I will repeat that answer but you
should all have figured this out.
The board will not stop just because
you hit the shore. Okay? Bought it.
Keep moving because there's no force
on the board is going to keep moving.
The question is how come I suddenly
have momentum in my system when I had no
more met them before? It's because the
ethics journal has now come into play.
Previously it was just you and the
boat and you couldn't change your total
momentum,
but the ground is not pushing you as
obviously pushing you to the right because
you were flying to the left and you
were stopped. So your combine system,
you end up board have right word forced
acting for the time it took to stop you.
It's that momentum that
scattered by the boat.
Better way to say this is you and the
board exchange Momenta you pushed the
board of the right,
you move to the left and your momentum
is killed by the shore. The board,
no reason to change.
It keeps going so you can calculate.
Can you calculate how
fast the board is moving?
Yeah. Anybody telling me how to
calculate how fast the board is moving?
Uh, but I am. I am on the
shore now fallen on the shore.
I'm asking you how fast
the boat is moving.
Cool.
Right? I think the, I think
I just got the right answer.
If I only told you that I
jumped and landed on the shore,
that's not enough to predict
how fast the boat is moving.
But if I told you my
velocity when I was airborne,
then of course I know my momentum and you
can find the board momentum and that's
the velocity it will retain forever.
So you need more information than
simply saying I jumped to the shore.
It depends with what velocity I left
the boat and landed on the ground.
If I leave really hard, the boat
will go really fast. The opposite.
Okay,
okay, that's the end of this family
have a central mass problems,
so I'm going to do a
another class of problems.
This in said rocket,
I just going to did I have the rocket
equation rockets something everybody
understand but it's a little
more complicated than you think.
Everyone knows you blow up a balloon,
you let it go, the balloon goes one way.
The ad goes the other way.
Action and reaction to an equal.
Even lay people know that.
Odd.
If you stand on a frozen lake and you
take a gun and you fire something but then
the bullet goes one way and you go
the opposite way again because of
conservation of momentum.
The rocket is a little more subtle and
I just want to mention a few aspects of
it. I don't want to go into the
rocket problem in any detail.
It's good for you to know
how these things have done.
Here's the rocket whose mass at this
instant, this m was. The velocity is v.
Right now
what rockets do is the emit gases and
the gases have certain exhaust velocity.
That velocity is called the zero in
magnitude is pointing away from the rocket
and it has a fixed value relative with
the rocket not related to the ground.
If you're writing with the rocket and
you look at the fumes coming out to the
back,
they will be leaving you at that
speed be not a short time later.
What happens short time later,
the rocket has a mass m
minus Delta because it's lost
some of its own body mass
in the form of exhaust fumes,
exhaust fumes.
I'm just showing them as a blob here and
the rockets velocity and now is not B
but B plus Delta v
and what's the velocity of the fumes?
Here is where you gotta be careful.
Your velocity was V at that instant.
The last year of the rocket fuel with
the to the ground is B minus v zero.
That's the part you got to understand.
Rocket has the smaller mass and bigger
velocity. Everyone understands that. What?
What's the momentum of the gas
leaving the rocket if the Mass Delta,
but what does its velocity?
Its velocity with the specter of the
rocket is pointing the left at Vizio,
but the rocket itself is going
to the right at speed. B.
Speed of seen from the
ground will be B minus vizio.
So the law of conservation of momentum,
we'd say m times V is equal to
m minus Delta Times v Plus Delta v
Let's Delta Times v Minus v zero.
This is momentum before
and momentum after equal.
So you open up this bracket,
you get
sideways letters better be uniform.
This is MV than Minus v dealt,
I don't want to call it Delta v I want
to call it v Delta Plus Am Delta v
Minus Delta planes,
Delta B plus Delta v Minus Delta Times
v Zero I want to call it be Zero Delta
please. And I want to put the belt
on the right is you may get confused.
Delta usually stands for the change
of something so I don't want,
that's not what I mean.
So you can sell this MV
and you cancel this Mv.
You cancel this v Delta
and that's be delta.
This one you ignore because it's the
product of two infinite decimals.
One is the amount of gas in a
small time, Delta t, others infant.
As much change in velocity,
we keep things with a linear.
This then you get the results m times
Delta v is equal to v Zero Times Delta.
Okay,
so I'm going to write it as Delta v over
B zero is equal to Delta over there.
This is the relation between the
change in the velocity of the rocket,
the velocity of the exhaust
gas as seen by the rocket.
The I'm on emitted in the small time
divided by the mass at that instance,
but what in in the sense of calculus,
what is the change in the mass of the
rocket? If Amazon mass of the rocket,
what would you call this?
A change the mass of the rocket
in this short time.
Okay.
Yup. Yup. No, no, no.
In terms of the symbol,
see at what's the change in the
mass of the rocket is Delta,
but he's really speaking minus Delta.
If you keep track of this sign they
change in the variable is really negative
and Delta here at Stanford
a positive number.
So if you remember that you
would write this minus d m o m.
Well the rest is simple mathematics.
I don't want to do this.
When if you integrate this
side and integrate that I
and you know DM over amis a
logarithm,
you will find the results
and you would find that is out that the
V at any time is the final going to be
initial plus.
Maybe I might've saw
do this integral here.
This integral will be the final might
minus v initial over v zero will be the
log of an initial over m final
so you will find the final,
he's v an issue plus v zero
log an initial what am fine,
I'm doing,
it's rather fast because I'm not that
interested in following this equation any
further. It's not a key question like
what I've been talking about now.
Yeah,
so this is a show you how we can apply
the law of conservation of momentum.
I'm not going to hold you responsible
in any great detail for the derivation,
but that is a formula that tells you the
velocity of the rocket at any instant.
If you knew the mass at that incident.
Yeah,
the rocket will pick up speed and it's
mass and keep going down and the log of
the mass before to the mass after Times
v not is the change in the velocity of
the rocket.
Okay,
so I have to give you some more
ammunition to do your homework problems.
I'm going to discuss the
last and final topic,
which is the subject of collisions.
So we are going to take the
collision of two bodies,
one body other than body m
One v one m two feet too.
They collide at the end of the day.
You're going to have the same two
bodies moving, get some velocities.
The one frame B, two prime. I would
go list to find the final velocities.
That's a goal of physics.
I tell you what's happening now I'm asking
you what's happening later. So here,
here's one.
There are two conditions you need because
you're trying to find two unknowns,
right? If you want to. Onwards I need two
innovations. One equation always true,
so let me write that down.
Always drew,
always true is the condition
that the momentum before
is the momentum after and One v one
prime plus aim two feet to prime.
You need a second equation to solve for
the two unknowns and that's where there
are two extreme cases. What are which
I can give you the second equation.
The one extreme case is
called totally inelastic
in a totally inelastic coalition.
The two masses stick together.
That means to be one frame and Vitu
prime but not too unknown for a single
unknown v Prime.
Then it's been easy to solve for the
momentum because they stick together and
move as a unit so you can right here.
That is equal to m one m
two times that the prime,
so you get v Prime is m One v one plus
M Two v two or and m one plus m two
that's a simple case boot.
Things hit stick together and
we'll wear the common speed.
The common speech should be so that the
total momentum like grease what you have
before.
That's called total inelastic.
Other category is called totally elastic.
Yeah.
In a totally elastic collision,
Kennedy energy is conserved
that you can write as a following
relation involving quadratic things.
M One v one square plus one half and two
we have two square is equal to one half
m one B one Prime Square.
There's one half m to be two prime square.
You can,
it turns out juggle this equation and
that equation and solve for v one prime
and B to cry.
Okay,
well I'll tell you what the answer is.
I don't expect you to keep solving it.
The answer is that the one prime is equal
to m one minus m two over m one plus m
two Times v One plus two m two four.
What am one was him to be
too, Lisa? No great secrets.
You will find them in any textbook
if you cannot follow my handwriting.
It running out of time.
Yes.
What you should be understanding now
is that better formula for the final
velocity when the coalition historically
elastic or totally inelastic.
If the total inelastic, it's what I
wrote there be one prime miss something.
Totally elastic.
You have a formula like this one,
so here you just to be placed everywhere
you saw an m one you put a name to
2:00 AM 1:01 AM 1:00 AM to be one.
Don't waste too much time writings.
I think you can go home and fill in
the blanks. It's in all the books.
What you carry in your head is there's
enough data to solve this because I will
tell you the two bodies,
I'll tell you [inaudible] I
tell you the initial velocities,
plugging the numbers, you
get the final, the last.
Remember this elastic inelastic coalition.
This is in one dimension.
Now I'll give you a typical problem.
Where do you have to be very careful in
using the law of conservation of energy?
You cannot use the law of conservation
of energy in an inelastic collisions.
In fact,
they ask you to check if two bodies
take two bodies identical with opposite
velocities, total
momentum, a zero they slam,
they sit together as a lump.
They got no kinetic energy in the end.
In the end. At the beginning
they had both had kinetic energy.
So kinetic energy is not conserved in a
totally in Alaska collusion in elastic
collision. It is. So here is an example
that tells you how to do this carefully.
Yes.
So this is called the belly dick.
So if you have a Bistol,
you matter of fact that a pistol,
the bullets coming out of the pistol at
certain speed and you want to tell the
customer what the speed is.
How do you find it?
Well nowadays we can measure these things
phenomenally well with all kinds of
fancy techniques down to 10 to the
minus 10 seconds. In the old days,
this is the trick people had. You go and
hang a chunk of wood from the ceiling
and then you find the bullets with some
Speed v zero and you know its mass.
Exactly.
The bullet comes ramps into this chunk.
So I cannot draw one more picture.
So you guys imagine though,
will it is embedded in this.
I think you also know intuitively
the minutes is embedded.
The whole thing sets in motion.
Now you could put this on a table.
Forget all the road. If you can find
the speed of the entire combination,
then by using conservation of momentum,
you can find out the speed of the bullet,
but that's hard to measure.
People have a much cleverer than idea.
You just ram into this thing. This is like
a pendulum, so the pendulum raises up.
Now put a certain maximum height
that you can easily measure
and from that maximum height you can
calculate the speed of the bullet.
So I'm going to conclude by telling you
what equations you're allowed to use the
two stages to be.
Pay attention and then we're done.
In the first coalition when
the bullet Ram into this block,
you cannot use law of conservation
of energy. In other words,
you might be naive and say,
look, I don't care about what,
what happened in between.
Finally,
I got a certain energy m plus M Times v
Times eight that's my potential energy.
No kinetic. Initially I had
minus one half m zero square.
I equate these two guys and I found zero.
That will be wrong.
That's wrong because you cannot use the
law of conservation of energy in this
process.
When I tell you that is a
totally inelastic collision
in the middle because what
will happen to some energy will
go into heating up the block.
It might even cats fired if
the boiler's going too fast,
but you can use the law of conservation
of momentum momentum all the time in the
first coalition to did use that m plus m
times some intermediate velocity is the
incoming momentum.
You understand that from that you can
find the Velocity v with which this
composite thing, block and bullet, we'll
start moving. Once it start moving,
it's like a pendulum with
initial momentum or energy,
it can climb up to the top and convert
the potential to candidate candidate
candidate. The potential. There is
no loss of energy in that process.
Therefore,
if you extract this velocity and
took one half m plus m times,
this is the last new square. You may
in fact equate that the impalas MGH,
so let me summarize this last result.
In every collision,
no matter what momentum is conserved,
energy may or may not be,
and if it gives you a problem like this,
where in that some funny business going
on with this, not energy conserving,
don't use energy conservation
from start to finish,
you use momentum conservation.
Find the speed of the composite object.
This is what you got understanding.
You'd had this not this equation.
When can I use conservation of mechanical
energy when Kenny not bullet driving
into a chunk of wood? You better. No, you
cannot use conservation of Kennedy, Ghana,
but once the combination is going up,
trading candidate for the potential,
you can.